hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching a film that won ten
Oscars it also is about an hour and a
half too long and that is Titanic I put
on my best rose cosplay well I'm not
like the full-on cosplay with this
because that would have just been no
clothes and YouTube frowns upon that so
I'm very excited to talk about it let's
do it
hooray yes good
[Music]
I wrote Jane Cameron's Titanic the
prequel Tabata the first half is a chick
flick which I'm super into the second
half was a terrifying ugly action horror
were some parts longer than they need to
be I think so probably though I enjoy
like all of it some of this script was
just unbearable like some of the 90s ass
writing young Lee oh oh oh I'm so glad
he finally won that Oscar Lee oh yes we
start off with the character Brock who
loved it
who gives us so much exposition they're
like well I need to know the story of
the Titanic but how long do we have only
three and a half hours so like let's
wrap this part up the Titanic sunk at
this time on this date this many people
died and then all this other stuff
happened and other things too - so bah
nothing's happening I didn't know that
this movie had this element to it though
I thought it was just all about their
story on the Titanic I had no idea this
whole exposition in this whole
expedition to find this necklace this
one exactly I own it this was $12 at a
convention so she goes to help the
expedition to find this and to just at
least tell her story about it the script
though leaves a lot to be desired it's
been 84 years and I still smell fresh
then you see young rose and you see her
super pretentious collection of Picasso
paintings I roll I roll I roll then I
just wrote down Lola
Kathy Bates girl so ROS is super sassy
and her fiance is an uptight mean guy so
she decides to jump from the ship makes
a ton of sense
so you've seen jack before this but this
is when they first interact and he's
trying to talk her off of the edge of
the ship but then he asks her have you
ever been to Wisconsin it's like dude
you're trying to talk her off of the
edge maybe mention California hail as
oldest time she doesn't want to get
married to her stuffy fiance she feels
trapped she buys a cute poor starving
artist she's chic chic says she she
shanks shanks a ship she sinks the ship
and it's done over and over all the time
it always happens that way up until like
the 3/4 mark of this film the fee is it
as bad as this is so mean and bad and
like not not at all like women's
strength of me but he's not as bad as he
could be like in the time period they're
at like early 1900s
like he's rich and like seems like he's
trying a little bit at first I was like
okay I understand you you like leo cause
like he's attractive and is an artist
absolutely I 100% I'm on board
but also like if you have to marry this
guy to ensure your future your mom's
future and like it's 1912 so maybe just
do it he just gave you that then he hits
her on my oh just kidding then you hit
the scene after he saved her where he
goes to dinner at the fantasy suite and
he dresses up and there's obvious
chemistry between Jack and Rose and I'm
such a sucker for good chemistry that I
was like smiling from ear to ear while
watching it and then she sneaks away and
he sneaks away and they go to the real
party down
Aires and it's just it's really fun for
me the most unrealistic part and the
party scene downstairs is that she just
picks up the footwork of the dance that
he's doing like immediately like he's
like beep beep boop bop beep boop boop
and she's like Fifi boob at beat FUBU
like that's that's not how that works
super fun totally getting into it then
something just really takes me out of it
her getting on her toes it was so weird
the house that I just do that
that cat kind of like points ballet no
stop
oh then she's forbidden from seeing him
but she's nothing I'm gonna go like this
I'm a ship my heart will go on and
so we have this really nice steamy
moment between Jack and Rose and then we
go to old Rose and we just skip to this
clip if we're going you mean did we do
it
way to ruin the mood movie I I'm gonna
draw you like one of my french girls
I think I nailed it
the lines are so corny where to miss to
the stars oh shit there's an iceberg I
hope everyone's alright then
this ship starts to sink and it becomes
a terrifying nightmare
of stress and panic so cow roses fiance
is trying to get her to board a lifeboat
and she wants to be with Jack so she
spits in his face and she's like I'm
done with being polite goddammit and I'm
like yes that is my 2018 anthem oh I was
never polite then I wrote also still an
hour and 15 minutes left
oh oh the band mates just tears oh my
god the old couple the children and the
mom the single mother
okay we're at the door part here's my
thoughts honestly I think it makes sense
I have always heard the door thing but
like oh there's plenty of room on the
door and there was plenty of room on the
door but I don't think it would have
floated with them both on it and they
did make a small kind of effort to show
that it wouldn't have floated then you
get a lot of old rose talking about how
she moved on I found happiness and
marriage of their places which is fine
I'm all about being happy even the best
of your situation but it just felt wrong
it felt wrong because like damn he just
like he didn't get on that door with you
girl he could they got on the door and
you guys couldn't kind of flown in but
he didn't and you lived because of it
and he died and you loved him so much
and you moved on it so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna walk away from that what
oh wait she throws out the heart of the
ocean the rose find cute whatever give
it back to the ocean give it back to him
that's fine well I understand I
understand in the story wife I
understand I get it
it makes sense script wise on paper but
then you see the love that they have
between each other and I know she's a
hundred and something years old whatever
money doesn't mean anything to her it
means a lot to other people you know
donate it but whatever
fine that's fine throw it into the ocean
for me mo to eat but whatever
maybe you should be buried in it if
you're gonna waste it like that be
buried with it it's like have him with
you always kind of thing why throw it
the ocean was his demise I really loved
that the last shot of her is with her
and then it pans to a shot of her on the
beach on the horse like they talked
about doing her and Jack
this was a super wonderful feel-good
movie until it wasn't and then when it
wasn't damn was it not and I also loved
not feel good it's to be it was perfect
for me Lindsey Ellis says Titanic is
good as a hundred and fourteen lights on
Twitter so waken I can't argue with that
this is my jack
it's so bad you'll be like I won't fall
for it at first and then Oh cry non-stop
yes that is exactly what happened how
have you not seen Titanic I don't know
man I was Amish hashtag Tamra was Amish
you will do that I'm flying jack I'm
king of the world moment with Ike I'm
the king of the world
I've overwhelmed the responses by this
I'm gonna try to physically respond to
these on Twitter thank you so much for
the predictions thank you so much for
watching I had such a good time watching
this I will see you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]